how do we get a message guy we're
committed to winning you wouldn't be
coaching this league if you weren't
committed to winning you know i think
that's a little bit of a silly narrative
there um
because we're doing everything we can to
be a championship caliber team and if
you come in our building and you feel
the energy from our scouting department
our coaches our players you'd have no
question about that and i think that the
players that get a chance to spend time
with the players we have on our roster
and this coaching staff will know that
it's something that people want to be on
board with and there's great days ahead
for the bankers
zach taylor bengals coach from the
combine last week nice guy great guy
tough situation because the bengals over
the years have been regarded as a team
that struggles to be competitive yes
they've been to two super bowls but it's
been a long time since the last time
that happened yes they had five straight
playoff appearances in the grand scheme
of the nfl though which focuses more on
recent accomplishments it's been a long
time since they've had a playoff caliber
team they now reportedly are
trying to change the narrative by being
heavily involved whatever that means in
the upper and middle level free agents
uh which would be a first for the
bengals peter you covered the bengals
before free agency but you saw some of
the frugality that makes it difficult
for the bengals to be competitive do you
really think they're gonna break out the
crowbar and start spending a bunch of
money uh just to change the narrative
and will it work
i don't think they would do it just to
change the narrative mike mike brown is
uh is not one of these guys who gives a
flying squirrel about the narrative
quite honestly
because he's whoa
oh you made me nervous there you heard
that didn't you
here's the thing about mike brown
that if you consider what has happened
in the time that he has run the bengals
which has basically been three decades
you know he's never cared about what the
outside world thinks ever and he's not
going to start caring when he's 84 or
whatever he is years old so to me the
cincinnati bengals are going to do
basically what sort of duke tobin and
zach taylor direct them to do okay right
now if they get rid of andy dalton which
they certainly will
that means they would have 62 million
dollars under the cap heading into free
agency
if that happens
i still think you've got to ask yourself
do you really want to devote
18 million dollars to aj green right who
has missed 24 of the last 32 games with
injury who's in his 30s he's going to be
32 this year
and
do you really want to devote that much
money
to a guy who you don't know how many
games he's going to play
that to me is one of the maddening
things about the bengals that they just
assume okay we're gonna we're gonna keep
aj green i'll tell you what they should
do with aj aj green they should try to
tag and trade him yes just the way that
a bunch of teams i think with pass
rushers are going to do
try to tag and trade them and don't take
you know a low one or a high two or
something like that take basically
whatever you can get just to help
yourself in the draft could you imagine
if they tagged and traded aj green and
got let's say a mid three forum or a
four even okay
in the receiver crop this year there
were 45 receivers at the scouting
combine this is probably the best
receiver draft of all time i'm just
saying if i'm the bengals
give me emmanuel sanders in free agency
we'll spend a little money there and
then let me take two or three guys in
the draft you got tyler boyd you've got
guys
uh on your team right now who you can
sculpt into talent for the future and
have them grow with joe burrow yeah
and you make a lot of good points peter
there's no doubt about it i'm with you
the aj green situation is uh fascinating
you know because yet the bengals have a
chance to get some assets there i would
think that they could get a first round
pick for aj green even at his age with
the injury history i don't see it yeah
well we'll see i mean hang on a second
hang on a second yeah peter think about
this and this is where i think the
bengals blew it and this is one of the
reasons why i doubt that they have the
right expertise and and savvy to
maximize the value of their assets they
should have traded him at the deadline
yes they should muhammad sunu got a two
emanuel sanders got a three and a four
if you move him at the deadline you're
getting a one form you may not get one
now but they would have gotten one in
october mike the
the problem with you would not have
gotten a one in october because aj green
was somehow good
he didn't even play the whole year
uh there was a point where he shut it
down come on at the deadline
there's a point where he said screw it i
ain't going out on the field i don't
know that but i think the circumstances
suggest that
that that injury at a certain point
wasn't an injury
either can you say that a 31 year old
wide receiver who hasn't played the
whole year and you're not sure about his
health how can you say you're getting a
one for him that's crazy
what's crazy i don't think it's
a new got a two i i think you could you
could make this he's right and he was
playing well and maybe healthy maybe you
get a number two maybe you get into
bidding more i mean aj green's the type
of talent where i mean we're talking
about like a border hall of fame talent
guy here where you get green bay and new
england involved in a conversation for a
receiver it's very interesting wait he
wasn't playing i get you i know
i get it but peter
there's a big difference between whether
or not they decided to put him on the
field and whether he decided he wanted
to go on the field knowing that free
agency was looming versus whether he
would have been able if he had been
traded i mean the injury happened at the
beginning of training camp i feel like
over the last couple months of the year
it had more to do with business reasons
than injuries aj green there you know
there's a lot of things we gotta go yeah
we'll be right back we'll be right back
we've decided to hold over the aj green
conversation because we all had some
spirited comments to make and peter i
want to start with you as we continue
this joe burrow the presumptive number
one overall pick in the draft speaking
to the media last week said he'd like
the bengals to keep aj green around how
much of that is a factor when you
consider there is a bit of a delicate
dance there sorry bengals truthers but
it's the truth there's a delicate dance
to make joe burrow want to be in
cincinnati
look if if if your doctors
tell you that aj green is fit as a
fiddle
and there is no reason why he can't play
the next three years healthy
then i'm fine with paying him keeping
him everything like that
all i'm doing is looking at history and
i agree if you're joe burrow you want
some help you've just come from a place
where every player on your offense
almost every player could be an nfl
draft choice so
you know just think of this if you're
joe burrow you want help you don't know
these guys you don't know him at all but
you know you've heard of aj green famous
guy and all that stuff i doubt he's ever
met aj green i doubt he knows aj green
if you just say to joe burrow we're
going to give you help and go out and
get emanuel sanders or trade for a
receiver whatever it is go get a tight
end you know or develop one
my only point is
if you're going to pay aj green 18
million dollars either for this year or
in an average contract you better be
sure that these are fluky injuries and
not a sign of things to come well that
that's very real and that's an
interesting conversation because joe
burrow they could trade aj green and
give you a lot of young assets to grow
into the future so that could be fun too
we'll be back right after this with the
three-man weave
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports